it should make a noise that goes I got
nothing okay Raheel do you think
countries like France that ban the hijab
in certain public arenas are in the
right you know Canada York country
didn't they just pass a law that said
you can take your citizenship oath in
the soz we're talking about two separate
things
okay the hijab is the head covering the
red scarf that is worn by many women as
a religious obligation although it's not
required but our face covering is a
niqab what Canada has done is allowed a
woman to give testimony in with her face
covered and that is what my organization
the Council for Muslims facing tomorrow
has been lobbying the government to say
that the niqab the face covering which I
call a mask should be banned in all
public spaces yeah I mean there's
another thing where I've heard liberals
say well it's their culture they like it
women don't really like it right I mean
well I think that if a woman you're a
little brainwashed yeah if a woman says
that it's a choice and that she likes
being covered from head to toe in a sack
then I think she would she should see a
terrible image yeah and and you're at
your nose diamond very unassuming I know
how long have you had that uh since I
was 15 because it's real fashion Wow and
then I discovered that this was the best
place to have a diamond no one can steal
it but you know politically correct
people will never ask me why are you
wearing a hearing in your nose it was a
little four-year-old child on a subway
train
that said loudly to his mom she's
wearing a year in her nose at the moment
and I said no let him ask how else is he
going to learn I'm during a hearing in
my nose it's so there you go because
it's the best place to hide it haha
but what about an uncle who says I got
your nose and then
it hurts it hurts you had that uncle
there's nearly I got your nose guy yeah
well talking about noses okay
we all have yes we're all seem at it
we're all somatic people's well you have
a beautiful waspy nose but can you
believe that
yeah no Sarah do you think do you think
comedy can play a role in defusing the
appeal of bigoted and hypocritical
candidates like Donald Trump no please
yes we all do yes yes yeah Matt Lewis
who could have beaten Donald Trump in
the primary if neither Cruz Rubio or
Kasich are able to you mean I guess that
means somebody who didn't run Marc Maron
maybe somebody who didn't you need
somebody Ted Nugent like what kinda
jannat yeah as much as what we have
already right you know Ted you Ted
Nugent who once called Obama an inhuman
mongrel and then took offense when
people said it was racist
I love when they do it woody where are
you getting racism from inhuman [ __ ] I
just don't you know again way this is my
point I think he could have taken Trump
out yeah yeah I'd be somehow be worse
does the panel have a sense of how the
Supreme Court will come down on the
Texas abortion law oh this I mean so
this was perhaps the biggest abortion
case in 25 years it was argued this past
week before the Supreme Court also a
week in which bt-dubs Clarence Thomas
spoke from the bench for the first time
in ten years but right well also on a
promoting via promoting the movie sorry
nevermind it's making a joke but but you
didn't make it do you need a help movie
Oh what I think I'm sorry I'm high from
when we're getting high later
Clarence Thomas yeah yeah
so you know wish you were here two weeks
ago when I smoked pot on the show how
did that go it went awesome
you saw that ask monk Pratt right on the
show yeah [ __ ] deal with that during
that oh yeah at the end of the UH I
think before Antonin Scalia died
everybody thought it would be a 5-4
decision with Anthony Kennedy being the
swing vote now that Scalia is no longer
on the court the question is is it going
to be a 4-4 ruling in which case the
Texas law restricting abortions is
upheld but this policy is not applied
nationally or if Kennedy sides with more
liberal justices will it be five three
and it'll be struck down but another's
argument to the Supreme Court right well
this is the thing nobody ever votes
based on the Supreme Court but it is
arguably well the most important issue
it affects literally everything that
touches Americans lives I wonder whether
this is going to go on with them on I
think the look I think the president is
going to make a nomination and at the
end of the day I think there's gonna be
enough public pressure that at least
there will be a hearing and you know the
average time that a Supreme Court
nominee has been pending is like 67 days
he could make multiple appointments
between now and then I mean why they
wanted to proc and think about the idea
that people who describe themselves as
constitutionalist want to take one of
the most simple ideas in the
Constitution and deny this president
that and you know and is that about race
yes it is is it about questioning the
legitimacy of this president absolutely
is and it's got to be stopped and only
the American people can stop yeah
oh you're gonna win that right of course
got that up two points in the polls
yeah you know if these two points don't
be complacent out there ten times as
much money - he's raised ten times yeah
oh that's all right I got the people
right that's whose side I'm on the
people does FBI director James Comey
saying that he has closely involved the
investigation of Hillary's emails mean
that she should be taking the threat of
indictment more seriously I mean I feel
like this is a fantasy on the right that
her emails are gonna bring her down she
this is the Obama Department of Justice
who's looking into it
she had this private email server I mean
I don't know what's in there but it's
weird it looks like she's hiding stuff
it's a lack of transparency it's
illegitimate always look like she's
hiding stuff to people who want it to
look like she's hiding stuff didn't you
why does she have watching her Lisa
billion emails over why does she have a
private email wire why has the guy who
set up the private email now cut a deal
what do you think he's got a deal they
want to talk to him and he's been
granted immunity granted immunity which
is very typical in a case to allow the
prosecutor to talk to them the
investigators will talk and I think at
the end of the day whatever you imagine
jewelry's on I'm just saying I don't
know I don't know maybe it's nothing I'm
just saying I think that this is the oh
boy this is not this is not like this is
that a Republican which one this is the
Obama deal of justice it's looking into
something that looks fishy and looks
weird
I think the involvement of Comey says
the buck stops here this is not some
low-level prosecutor running amuck with
this case whatever the outcome is I'm
answering or I'm handling it I'm
overseas and that's what I think the
comeon home legitimate investigation and
then it's gonna be closed and then
Donald Trump is gonna get their
nomination and I think Hillary's gonna
get ours and she's gonna win the awash
if Donald Trump wins the nomination
listening
Republican Party is going to come upon
us what is so interesting I did they
made their bed this is their Donald
Trump is a manifestation no dark Donald
Trump is a hijack it's a hostile
takeover the Republican Party is it
isn't representing your mongering and
then when someone comes to the first and
blames Mexicans and Muslims and the
American people embrace it that's that's
from them they've been primed yeah and
yeah I mean I hear this all the time the
party is broken yeah the people are
broken too
I mean I'm sorry to say that we see you
talk about the Democratic Party that
says that women who support Bernie
Sanders are sellouts to their gender are
traitors to their gender what about that
is bullying in fear-mongering or you go
to it but in a much smaller little yeah
are people who listen there are Bernie
Bros on the Hillary side they they say
if you don't vote vote for Hillary
you're not a feminist and and if you
vote for Bernie then the Republicans
will win and so you know that's like
self-fulfilling prophecy stuff but I
know that I'm a FEMINIST and I'm voting
for Bernie so I've just see bumped up I
think for Republicans they've got such a
mess in their party that they want us to
have a mess too and what we actually
have is a legitimate debate between two
highly qualified seem to debate here
like immediately to smart people you
know about you must be with it without
Donald Trump it you must been you might
look Donald Trump is a guy who invited
Hillary Clinton to his wedding who
supports plant support listen he's a
liberal steal a bottle together Donald
Trump is alive i he supports mundane
Planned Parenthood he supports eminent
domain supports single he's on both
sides of every one of those issues he's
a liberal and if you take him out the
Republican Party has a place to start
house they have hardly a builder right
and what do you have left you have a
crews who shut down the government and
you have Marco Rubio who was you know
against immigration before he was poor
immigrants they're shaken because
they've all agreed on the same set of
Lies and somebody's shaking it up a
little bit I don't think a guy who
supports killing terrorists families can
be described as a no he changed on that
today and waterboarding and worse did
you hear what is so terrific but he
changes a lot
he changes is [ __ ] opposed but I loved
I saw that clip my god is ditto yes yes
you know today he'll smash slam you
tomorrow he says he loves you so he's
either very dysfunctional
he's an authoritarian to that's what
concerns me the most right I mean by the
way I don't if you sell the Vox piece
yes the number one predictor if you're a
Republican who likes Trump versus a
Republican who doesn't is your
propensity toward authoritarianism that
is the key divide well yes but when you
talk about Muslims the there was a poll
that said that eleven percent of
American Muslims are in favor of Trump
know what
and also he gets some Latino yeah this
is a lot like one in every crowd is what
I I feel like a lot of the people taking
these polls are a lot like the hundred
people surveyed and uh that was our
favorite show hey you cannot
family-ready really I think I'm
brain-damaged I'm glad think the vapes
cause more damage you plug it into a
what am i doing
you know you're just you just be
traveling to your own drummer you're
saying I start sentences I don't have to
finish that's been done finishing
sentences
hydron are do you see the circle right
so I wanted I never got to ask you this
you are you have a mixed marriage yes
Europe Shiite no my husband's from a
Shiite family I'm from a Sundy family
and I do sushis and that used to be
fairly common it's I mean before we
invaded Iraq that was common in Baghdad
right yes it was it was common in
Baghdad and actually people said that if
this war happens it's going to take
place in the bedrooms of the people in
back that they were intermarriages and
at the time I got married it was still a
bit taboo so both of us sort of ran away
from home and came abroad and people
took a bet that this was not going to
last
so in June it'll be 40 years and I'm
sure there are certain small differences
like holidays and stuff like that but
but in general when you have a
disagreement I'm sure you can say to
each other but we agree on 95 percent
we're all on the page with Allah
Mohammed this is a course I don't know
if everyone can agree to disagree right
we can all learn to get along together
if we learn to respect each other's
differences that's what it's about
unfortunately that is not what religion
is greater we know religion is good at
that
legend is always about my way or the
highway oh my god is better than yoga
but eventually we all realize that if
you're a believer it's the one and only
God so you know we need to learn to get
over these political differences you
know which is so much more about
patriarchy and power and politics in my
part of the world and that's what the
struggle is you know the struggle is for
power and hegemony it's not about being
a kinder nicer person
and once we if we are able to what what
I would like to ideally see is this
American Islam indigenous American Islam
which is pure pluralistic
democratic liberal loving of everyone
accepting of everyone right an accepting
of those who have no faith also which is
something you don't see in the Muslim
world and that indigenous American Islam
is going to save thousands of Jen the
next generation of young here here thank
you what a great final word Thank You
audience